lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comparar las fracciones siete décimos
con ocho novenos y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta y traten
de decidir si éste es más grande que
este otro o al revés o si son iguales en
este vídeo yo quiero analizar esto
visualmente y quiero hacerlo usando
enteros del mismo tamaño que son
círculos estos son círculos del mismo
tamaño y voy a comparar siete décimos de
este círculo con ocho novenos de este
otro círculo que es un círculo del mismo
tamaño que el anterior es el mismo
entero ya que si comparáramos siete
décimos de un círculo pequeño con ocho
novenos de un círculo grande o alomejor
siete décimos de un círculo grandote y
ocho novenos de un círculo pequeñito
pues no podemos realmente compararlos
aquí vamos a comparar siete décimos del
mismo entero con ocho novenos de
exactamente el mismo entero pueden ver
en esta forma en que pre dibujo
estos enteros que los círculos son del
mismo tamaño pero están divididos en
diferentes partes iguales aquí como
tengo decimos lo divide en uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
secciones y aquí como me interesan los
novenos ven que dividí esto en uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
secciones ahora veamos cómo
representamos siete décimos van a ser
siete de estas diez secciones vamos a
colorear las tenemos una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis y siete de estas diez
secciones y ahora vamos a representar
ocho novenos aquí vamos a iluminar ocho
de nuestras nuevas secciones una dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho cuál
de éstas es más grande pues vemos
claramente que si gráfica mos ocho
novenos del mismo entero y siete décimos
del mismo entero
hemos coloreado más del entero que
corresponde a los novenos
parado con lo que colorea mos en azul
así que 8 novenos es más grande que 7
decimos podemos decir que siete décimos
es menor que ocho novenos nuevamente la
forma en la que yo recuerdo cuál símbolo
usar es que siempre queremos que esta
abertura esté del lado del número más
grande y está apunta va a estar del lado
del número más pequeño siete décimos es
menor que ocho novenos